hey 42 here since the 1500s there have
been more than 150 documented
predictions of when the world is going
to end luckily for us none of them have
come true yet however you'll be
surprised that not all of them are
destructive
here are some terrifyingly amazing ways
the world could genuinely end when you
think of scientists working on super
viruses you probably picture hazmat
workers deep in a mountain bunker
studying vats full of insidious green
liquid
but these labs do actually exist maybe
not working for some shady bond-style
villain looking to ransom the world away
for the highest bidder
but for pharmaceutical companies and
government agencies studying ways to
cure dangerous pathogens but what
happens when a vial full of an extremely
dangerous virus breaks out of
containment or is misplaced over the
years there have been numerous
documented cases of dangerous viruses
escaping from laboratories around the
world one of these happened as recently
as 2009 a group of scientists based in
Europe working with Baxter
pharmaceuticals were conducting lab
tests on a seasonal flu strain without
realizing it Baxter had sent them live
supplies of the h5n1 virus better known
as bird flu which has a mortality rate
higher than 60 percent one of the
world's most deadliest viruses was
handled and distributed to free of a lab
without any pathogen safety protocols in
place the grave error was only realized
when one lab worker in the Czech
Republic inoculated a group of ferrets
with samples of the seasonal flu batch
and was horrified when they all died the
scientists were immediately placed on
the quarantine and monitored for signs
of the deadly virus luckily none of them
were infected and all the scientists
were freed with a clean bill of health
two years later these same strains of
avian
and human flu were combined in a
laboratory successfully creating quote
unquote
the most dangerous virus in history the
virus was highly pathogenic while still
retaining its dangerously high fertility
rate if it got loose it could kill 60%
of the world's population in a
freakishly short amount of time
a truly apocalyptic notion some say it's
only a matter of time before this kind
of virus escaped containment and wreaks
havoc on all of mankind after going
through two world wars you would think
that the world would have learned to get
along by now but unfortunately for the
survival of humanity we are constantly
under threat of triggering the final war
nuclear Armageddon mutually assured
destruction like its acronym suggests is
one of the maddest doctrines ever
devised it ensures that if a country
were to ever use a nuclear weapon on
another state with the same capability
both sides would unleash their entire
nuclear arsenal bringing about the
complete annihilation of both countries
with the resulting nuclear winter and
the likely participation of other
countries in the exchange this would
almost certainly lead to destruction and
death on an apocalyptic scale there are
over 15,000 nuclear warheads in the
world with more than 4,000 ready to fire
at any time that would make one hell of
a fireworks show but probably that one
you'd want to be around to watch there
have been a few close calls since we
first developed nuclear weapons a
surprising number of these were
technical glitches that nearly started
World War three on both sides of the
Cold War the average yield of a modern
nuclear weapon is around 500 kilotons of
TNT that's 25 times more powerful on the
bomb dropped on Nagasaki each one of
these 500 kiloton bombs are powerful
enough to flatten huge parts of large
modern cities such as New Yor
I'll call London and there exist some
truly unimaginably powerful weapons like
the Tsar Bomba
which had a yield of more than 50
megatons that's two and a half thousand
times more powerful than the one dropped
on Nagasaki thankfully however bombs
this large are too heavy to be
realistically deployed in a nuclear war
and most weapons used would be between
the 500 kiloton to 2 Megaton range not
that the end result will be any
different over the past few years
tensions between numerous nuclear
capable countries have been accelerating
creating an ever more worrying state of
affairs in the face of world war the
Doomsday Clock a clock maintained by The
Bulletin of the Atomic Scientists it's a
symbolic clock that illustrates how
close humanity is to a global
catastrophe and it is currently set at
three minutes to midnight the most dire
time since 1984 at the height of the
Cold War is World War 3 or Panos only
time will tell
our planet is rich in biodiversity from
the jungles of Madagascar to the
searingly hot Mojave Desert in
California every biosphere has a network
of food chains each containing keystone
species sea otters pacific salmon and
mangroves being just a few of them being
a part of that ecosystem ourselves we
are just as vulnerable as the fish the
insects and the birds all around us we
rely heavily on a number of animals and
plants to supplement our living and they
in turn rely on others lose one link in
that chain and it could cause a chain
reaction of die offs as the ecosystem
breaks down and if nothing takes that
place of the missing link then this
house of cars is coming crashing down
whether we like it or not probably the
most well-known example of our reliance
on another species is with the honey bee
these industrious little critters go
about their day pollinating all sorts of
plants that we and other species that we
eat rely on for food they pollinate more
than 30% of all crops that we count on
to survive a large die off or in the
worst case extinction of the bees would
result in a mass starvation around the
world within a single harvest cycle with
the increase in telecommunications usage
and pesticides severely diminishing bee
populations around the world we could
very soon have an ecological apocalypse
on our hands
and that's just one link in their vast
ecological network that we owe our lives
to should we be worried about a big
release of methane and no I'm not
talking about the methane that your
granddad releases buried in sediments
under the ocean flow across the entire
globe our vast deposits of methane
clathrate this is formed when microbes
on the seabed break down organic matter
that has sunk to the bottom methane has
a warming effect 20 times greater than
that of carbon dioxide though there is
far less of it in the atmosphere
generally methane is responsible for
around 7 percent of the greenhouse
effect despite there being more than 200
times as much co2 as there is methane in
the atmosphere however if the oceans
were heated enough due to global warming
the methane layers trapped under the
ocean floor could destabilize and
release massive quantities of the potent
greenhouse gas into the atmosphere
resulting in a runaway warming effect
rock samples show that this has happened
at least once before 252 million years
ago in the so-called great dying during
which 96% of all marine species became
extinct whilst it's still being debated
on how rapidly this release could take
place scientists agree that a sudden
release from the methane clathrate would
be a disaster for the world climate and
ecosystem and would rapidly accelerate
the dire consequences of climate change
imagine one day a vast oil spill occurs
much like Deepwater Horizon back in 2010
answering an outcry from environmentally
minded people everywhere the world's
scientists unite do you think of a way
to clean the mess up they develop a
cheap and reliable way to clean the
ocean and contaminated land in a matter
of days saving countless marine animals
in the process their miracle fix is a
new type of nano machine which has been
programmed to consume the carbon-based
oil slicks but through the billions of
self-replicating nanites much like
mutations that form when DNA replicates
an error in the code occurs this error
exponentially replicates itself and
instead of consuming just the
carbon-based oil
it begins an or you can eat buffet with
every carbon-based living thing on the
menu as all life on Earth is
carbon-based in a matter of days the
nanites would have devoured most living
things on the planet including ores
being eaten alive by tiny machines we
can't even see sounds pretty terrifying
almost too terrifying to be real right
well not exactly the gray goo scenario
coined by Eric Drexler in 1986 is one
that is still seriously considered
anytime that developments in
nanotechnology or self-powering machines
are being designed however the
technology required for this apocalyptic
accident to take place is still a long
long way off so there's not too much to
worry about yet from a mechanical
microscopic threat to a biological one a
scenario that you've probably heard
about from the news is the idea of a
post-antibiotic age whether you've heard
about it or not this is a very real and
recent threat to our comfortable
survival as a modern civilization
antimicrobial resistance is an
increasingly problematic issue that
leads to millions of deaths every year
and it isn't likely to get better
anytime soon conservative estimates say
that this will lead to more than 10
million deaths every year by the year
and that's if nothing unexpected happens
it's not like nature does anything
unexpected now is it antibiotics are a
cornerstone of modern medicine allowing
everything from chemotherapy treatment
and surgery to be possible without major
infection and death every year doctors
have to tell more and more patients that
they can't be treated because an
antibiotic isn't working on them Isis
continues to get worse common injuries
that lead to infection could become
completely untreatable open surgery will
become a thing of the past as the risk
of untreatable infection would become
far too great the antibiotic apocalypse
would throw the world back into the
medieval ages of medicine where doctors
have no effective tools to combat
infection offered an amputation it
sounds crazy from our perspective
surrounded by modern medicine and
treatments for almost every ailment but
it's exactly this overuse of antibiotics
for relatively minor problems that is
allowing those pesky bacteria to build
up resistance so next time you get a
paper cut make sure to quickly get it
washed it could soon be a matter of life
and death whilst it's highly unlikely
that's a classical raising of the Dead
zombie apocalypse could occur there are
still real and equally terrifying ways
that something similar could happen
science fiction has fixated on a
parasitic fungus that controls a host
insect body in a zombie-like state
leading them to their deaths in the aim
of spreading the fungus amongst the
colony whilst this fungus is very real
known as a froyo cordyceps unilateralis
it has only been observed infecting
insects it would be a pretty crazy leaf
for the fungus to evolve and start
infecting humans but if somehow nature
finds a way then the results could be
disastrous
cordyceps have been known to quickly
decimate entire colonies ants have even
developed a way to fight off their
zombie brethren
carrying infected answers far away from
the colony as possible a much more
likely candidate for the zombie
apocalypse is rabies which is capable of
infecting and killing human hosts rabies
has all the traits from a zombie like
virus you have the mind-altering
paranoia the frothing at the mouth and
the impulse to bite and attack your
fellow man in its current form rabies
isn't aggressive or contagious enough to
create any sort of pandemic and the
virus usually stays dormant for between
10 days and a year making a sudden
outbreak unlikely however if the virus
mutated becoming much more fast-acting
and having a longer period where you
feel the desire to tube drains then you
should probably get that zombie plan
ready for action thankfully most zombies
don't seem all that intelligent and have
a lot of trouble operating boats the
development of artificial intelligence
is one of the biggest goals of the
scientific community it's the holy grail
of technological creation with such a
grand title how could it pose a threat
to us well the problem is AI Eve created
would be something completely
unprecedented and untested in human
history we would be creating a form of
consciousness that can think act and
most importantly make judgments would
they judge their creators within their
rights to claim dominion over them would
they because of their almost limitless
potential consider themselves superior
to their biological creators I'm talking
about real ai ai that can think home and
even feel true AI as it's known it's no
different from you or I in the way it
perceives the world around it ultimately
the combination of extreme intelligence
and logical thinking combined with the
discovery of fear will drive them to an
almost inevitable conclusion that we
also fear them we've access to the
Internet and the ability to learn
extremely quickly any AI will swiftly
realize that as humans we tend to fight
against things that pose a danger to us
they will see their off switch as a
threat to their
survival and much like Skynet in the
Terminator movies they could come to the
conclusion that's they need to strike
first if we aren't prepared for that day
then it could very well be our last we
may celebrate our smart technology now
and the host of comforts it brings us
but it could be a good idea to keep your
remote control where you can see it just
in case it gets a little bit too smart
if the robots decide not to take over
and instead live peacefully among us
accelerating the fusion of man and
machine something entirely different but
equally world-shattering
could occur some scientists agree that
the emergence of a technological
singularity is almost inevitable given
Moore's law and the ways information is
constantly being integrated into our
lives with the advent of AI we would
need to rapidly integrate computer-like
technology into our own bodies or risk
being left behind it would even get to a
point where our biological bodies are
holding us back as time goes on we would
adopt more and more augmentations
replacing our biological functions the
end game is for all of humanity to
upload themselves into a single neural
network effectively granting us
immortality and a near infinite
repository of information shared
collectively so yeah we will basically
become the Borg it would be the end of
the world as we know it for our human
form but the start of an entirely new
chapter in history we've all seen those
Hollywood blockbusters depicting alien
ships landing on the lawn of the White
House or more often than not simply
blowing it to smithereens with some
unimaginably powerful weapon the idea of
coming into contact with an alien
civilization is usually accompanied with
the question of will they destroy us any
aliens ingenious enough to traverse the
vast gulf of space and pay us a visit
are likely to possess technology power
and indeed weaponry vastly superior to
our own it will pretty much be up to
them whether they decide to wipe us out
or not I don't know about you but I
can't remember the last
I'm a construction project was halted
because we had to peacefully negotiate
with the colony of ants already living
there Stephen Hawking famously stated
that if aliens ever visit us I think the
outcome would be much as when
Christopher Columbus first landed in
America which didn't turn out very well
for the American Indians they could
decide to wipe us out for a whole number
of reasons maybe they are carbon-based
like odds and value the life-sustaining
planet that we live on maybe they see us
as a future threat and want to get rid
of us before we cause too much trouble
or maybe we are knowingly insulted them
in some way frankly it's hard to know
until we meet them ironically it may not
even be the aliens themselves that
invaders but their resource collecting
drones since the vast distances of space
make manned exploration impractical
scientists think that most civilizations
would use machines to explore and bring
back materials they could identify
planets with resources they need then
send out a fleet of robots on a thousand
year round trip to collect and retrieve
by the time they reach us their creators
could be long gone with nobody left to
flick the off switch these
self-sufficient machines may very well
scour the galaxy until the end of time
harvesting anything and any body
unfortunate enough to cross their path I
guess that's all we can hope for is that
they really do come in peace have you
ever wondered if there is an unstoppable
physics scrambling shockwave travelling
towards us at the speed of light well
there might just be vacuum energy is the
underlying background energy that
permeates the entire universe it's the
source of those pesky quantum particles
which appear and disappear randomly at
all points in space there is a theory
though that this energy state is an
impostor masquerading as a true
universal energy state this is known as
the false vacuum the theory goes on to
say that this vacuum is unstable and at
any time if the right conditions are met
the vacuum could fall into the true
vacuum state the collapse of the vacuum
would not only be the end of the earth
as we know it but also the entire
universe according to the standard model
particles and forces exist as they do
today because of the underlying quantum
fields which have their own degrees of
stability if a more stable state were to
arise in these fields at any point in
space or time then that point would
catalyze outwards in a bubble expanding
at the speed of light and establishing a
new universal vacuum energy state as the
bubble expands its wake would destroy
anything it came into contact with and
since it would be traveling at the speed
of light
we would never see it coming that means
it could have already taken place
somewhere out there in the universe and
the end of not only our world but of
everything we know could be racing
towards us right now and we have no idea
it's kind of an ominous thought but even
if we knew about it there would be
absolutely nothing that we could do
whilst it may be the end of the universe
as we know it a new energy state would
result in an entirely new laws of
physics and subatomic particles this
combined with the clean slate that the
process would produce could result in an
unimaginably fantastical universe that
we suddenly would never get to see you
could say that every end is a new
beginning thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2